after 30 years working night shifts at
the checkout
this email confirmation pam is now in
line for equal pay
quite pleased to say the least i've put
myself
out and serve a lot of other people the
solicitors have done amazing
but it's just the principle of the thing
really i just
i can't see how fair it is for the jobs
are different
they're not the same jobs but they're of
equal value
staff working in tesco stores happen to
be mostly female
while those working in one of the
company's 23 distribution centers
are mostly men the pay gap between the
two has been up to three pounds an
hour more pay for warehouse work
the claimants lawyers had taken the case
to a tribunal in watford in early 2018
before brexit the european court of
justice therefore
able to claim jurisdiction what does it
mean
now if you can show that there's a
single source
i.e your employer can put it right you
get that chance
to have your work assessed to see if it
is actually of equal value
so it sounds so obvious doesn't it and
you're thinking why have we taken 50
years to do this and it's because it's
that right to compare a different job to
see if they are of equal value and it's
so
so important because now we get the
chance to have that comparison made
and that's a chance which could now be
applied to tens of thousands of workers
from
five of the big supermarket companies
and beyond
i shouldn't make the mistake of thinking
that this is purely about one
supermarket
in the retail sector it's not it's a
problem which is still affecting women
across all forms of employment in all
sectors in this country
now finally after months of legal
wranglings
pam and thousands of others could be
paid out thousands of pounds
harriet hadfield sky news west london